smart robots are no longer the stuff of
science fiction but intelligence is more
than besting humans at board games its
basic physical skills to like turning in
door knob or opening a back babies being
sensory information from the world
around them to figure out how to use
their bodies and interactive robots
aren't quite as sophisticated in the
past they feel pretty epically at
controlling their bodies but new
improvements could go a long way to help
machine since the world and learn new
skills based on what they see or hear
some senses are more easily mastered
than others
if you have an iPhone you might interact
with theory and acoustically astute
artificial intelligence that picks up on
your speech patterns to better respond
to questions theory
are you alive questions your existential
other senses are trickier take touch
humans are bombarded with tactile
information through skin temperature
pressure texture
researchers at the University of
Colorado took a similar approach with a
robot named Baxter they gave it smart
skin that translates a lot of vibration
data into simple messages Baxter sensors
can differentiate between 15 different
textures touch sensors also need to be
sealer about developed by a team at
Stanford where is durable sensors on
twirling legs soon it may be able to
tell hard ground from grass or sand and
adjust the way it scrambles forward but
there's a difference between fencing the
world around you and actually doing
something with that information
researchers at UCLA gave their robot
squishy sensitive finger pads and a
plastic bag fulla T riaz robot actually
figured out how to close the bag on its
own touch is a handy skill but staying a
brain is a pretty important one your
inner ear eyes and cheek i'll give you a
sense of balance some robot atlas are
equipped with body and legs sensors that
do the same thing that list might take a
tumble now and then but a new upgrade
enables the bot to get right back up
so that's hearing touch balance
what about site lasers can tell a robot
how far it is from an object or obstacle
Google's driverless car also uses lasers
radar cameras and software to recognize
the shape of a pedestrian or the
outstretched arm of a cyclist other
robots tackle even more complex visual
challenges star is a surgical robot with
senses that go beyond human abilities
it has 3d and near infrared cameras like
wearing night-vision goggles star can
see glowing dots marked by human tissue
calculate a stitch when show up a live
animal and maybe one day a human patient
stars makers hope to add more super
human senses to like measuring blood
flow things that seem like baby steps
for humans are giant leaps for robot
kind especially robots designed to work
in the real world sticky bad for example
is a deco inspired robot these special
toe pads to jail walls micro tugs are
teeny tiny robots that can haul
materials hundreds of times their body
weight smart physical sensors can make
these BOTS more aware of their
environment and allow them to focus on
more complex tasks one day such
sensitive robots might not work for us
or against us but alongside us